yo this is Gorilla nems check me out on
the bootleg Kev podcast for the 19th
time you know anytime I'm in La this is
the first stop your life
it's the bootleg Kev show
we have a special guest
his new album is out
it is a good album it is great album
fully produced by scram Jones absolutely
you've been talking about this album for
a while yeah it's about [__] time
it's about [__] time grilling nemes
is here ladies and gentlemen [__] your
life you [__] faces I'm back for the
17th time what's it like to
horrifying is it you don't know what
you're gonna do I remember punching out
car windows or I remember just not being
able to move I just I just remember
every time I smoked so I was just like
why the [__] did I do this would it be
like a like a cigarette like oh if I had
two two tests so when I said this on my
podcast outside with Gorilla Nims the
literally outside the best part it's
amazing you're killing it with that
number two after bootleg you had
Ghostface kill outside facts he was
freezing he didn't like and he's a
champion I was like bro you want me to
stop for a little bit like 10 minutes he
was like nah let's get this going it was
like this so
um yes I came home out of jail my man
gave me a jar of dust I'm like go get
your money I put you on I have no
clientele I just came out of jail right
right right so I just wound up just
dipping every cigarette and just being
my best customer get this fly out of
here throw this fly bro yeah
you can smoke
no we don't want a podcast
smoke sir and then you get the dust the
the the the the the the
tea leaves I guess right whatever they
do so you dip it no you put the flakes
from and Into the Blue
yeah oh wow what's the Highlight though
it's numbing
um like you just I want to try
I did that too
you got it before yeah y'all check this
I just remembered this story so
I'm hanging out with this girl for the
first time
and she's like yeah I know somebody guys
hey that wasn't really my thing but I'm
like whatever
she goes let's let's go rob this this
kid
I was like all right yeah why not yeah
all right yeah so I put him in the
headlock put them to sleep she goes
through his pockets takes
this is July 2nd my whole knows the year
years ago
so we take it to her house I didn't know
how to do it but apparently you put it
in either the microwave or like the oven
because it comes in liquid but you yeah
turn it into a oh you put it on a baking
sheet the liquid heat it up and then you
scrape it off and it becomes
like a powder okay do you eat it or do
you
so we do that
July 2nd do it
I'm smashing we both
all I remember is waking up July 5th
she's still bent over and I'm over her
and I was like yeah what the just
happened I look at I don't even know if
we had phones when I was doing it was
today it was July 5th I was like yo we
missed the whole fourth of July we
missed like three days what the [__]
happened we both still
like what did we just both pass out and
wake up three days later
holy [__]
wow wow I'm mad I didn't tell this on my
podcast pretty amazing
I'd like to point out that now I really
want to do it yeah yeah got to make sure
you do it with a woman though you gotta
do it with my grandma I don't know if my
wife will do it yeah man being a married
man and doing drugs just don't mix it
doesn't I only smoke weed and I spray
apparently boring yeah get a life hey
you're sober bro I know but which is
enough which is beautiful yeah what's
the worst
the worst drug is
it's a mix-up between
I would say dust it's not even a mixer
but me personally I know some people
that love smoking dust yeah I just hated
it I don't know why I ever did it every
time I was like literally why the [__]
am I doing this do you think if I was
around back then you would have tried it
nah well probably maybe on accident
right like you almost like probably
couldn't avoid it the last time I got
locked up
I was I was already sober for over 10
years right
so true fiends came in it was like yo
nems love your music yeah I knew they
was Finn so yo what's up man it was like
I was like what you got arrested for
they were like
I was like I thought that kills you know
I thought they nah we smoke it we put it
in uh in the um tin foil foil yeah like
I'm like damn I thought that I thought
like a little dose of would like kill
your ass yeah yeah so I guess now the
fiends are like desensitized bro if you
go like to or most places in L.A if you
just see homeless people there's just
foil everywhere they don't even wants
anymore they just want
they're like where's the yeah I'm saying
it's like
it was like this they always say it's
like this much will just kill you and
it's like smoking this much just smoking
what the I think it's all from China too
shout out to China man they got that
phone lock bruh certainly from Mexico
but he don't want to say he lives mad
close to Mexico well I think it comes
from China to Mexico and then it comes
over what is it I think I mean I I know
that they they give you the hospital
what happened to that crocodile
what remember you've never seen this
it's called crocodile crocodile they
were doing it in Russia or something
turns you your skin into like crocodile
hey there's some new [__] I heard out
here some like uh some sort of
tranquilizer people are doing this like
a horse tranquilizer that's what Special
K is well Special K is cat tranquilizer
cat tranquilizer wow well it could be
horse drink that's didn't have to be a
horse tranquilizer Wow Let's
tranquilized yeah put you out facts for
sure absolutely you ever do
nah you no I'm really scared I really
want to but I'm scared nah dude bro if
you're still doing this age bro you
might as well if you're taking spritzes
don't do
that
what do you got to lose yo your album is
amazing man thank you man I think it's
your best body of work
it's really good it's all to me already
yeah
for like no yeah yeah I know four years
yeah the whole pandemic me and scram is
working on it and you know so it's old
to me but always on release day I always
sit in the car and listen to it and for
some reason it sounds brand new to me
and I was like yo
this is a solid body of work I'm proud
of it yeah uh I mean shout out to
Ghostface Killah who [__] showed up
and showed out I think everybody that
gave me a verse on there like everybody
they showed up Chic Louch look at track
two yeah uh track three yeah Rise of the
Silver I couldn't have an album with
Silverback without cheek of course yeah
gun play pottied it killed it you got
gun place saying [__] your life facts I
love it facts did you guys hang out
no we we plan to and then I feel like
he'd be a fun hang me too okay I would
like just like to go do something random
with Gunplay like go to escape room or
something no I would love to have gun
play in Coney Island yeah because it's
like it's on the Block yeah bro get him
a chopped cheese yeah it'll be hilarious
it would be hilarious Yo I haven't
talked to you since well on the podcast
since I actually went to Coney Island
and like um when you say you run Coney
Island like uh
yeah it's true so like if anybody ever
like questions that like just go there
and you'll be like oh I see this [__]
G everywhere facts and then you just
like walk in and like just take [__] out
of the store and they're like you're
fine but I mean that's that's what the
mayor does the mayor of Coney Island
facts did you go and see well have you
ever seen Joey Chestnut in person eating
in Coney Island this year and last year
because I did an episode with those side
talk kids we did it last year at the
Nathan [__] so I saw it for the first
time ever in life
I was like yo this is so stupid standing
here ridiculous right and people were
mad because they were there from five in
the morning it was raining right this
year yeah so we went there this year I
said y'all I was about to come down come
on let's go inside luckily this year we
had a little more clout they gave us Pat
everybody knew who I was so they was
like yeah
so they was like yo just go in the back
and then
I saw Joey Chestnut he was like where
you are I'm here and he was just like
amping himself up I was like this is
this Lizzy God this is this guy's
[__] Christmas right here for sure
it's the Super Bowl yeah did you see the
big black dude who chugs on YouTube yeah
Badland chugs yo he raps in konia that
day he sucks that day of course Fourth
of July
he's like one of the hosts for the
Glizzy contest so he [__] raps he
does some corny ass freestyle [__] yeah
he's true I be hate watching his [__] on
YouTube bro like it pops up on my
algorithm because I watched him like
once and it's like he'll like I'm just
like I feel bad because I feel like that
fool's gonna die soon and like his whole
livelihood is him like killing himself
on video yeah that's crazy he like bull
chug like he'll take like a 12 pack of
like some new soda and emptied into one
thing and then take it to the [__]
face to chug to chug this in one shot it
you can't do it no no I could
right now bro
guarantee you can't do it in one shot I
guarantee I can I'm a shark I shotgun
beers bro
and soda is two different things bro
there's no soda in there
you don't got most energy in here no you
don't you're not on Team Monster bro
nobody that doodle he'll [__] put
like 12 like he'll [__] take he has
this big boot and he puts like like the
Grimace Shake yeah the McDonald's bro he
put like four of them into this boot and
then chugged it all at once and I'm like
this dude's brain freeze gotta be
[__] wild son yo another
um
it's just one fly the whole bro earlier
today I took my hat off in the interview
and I try to [__] nail it yo you
gotta freeze them out bro just don't
even got you don't got no AC on man
that's over there it's over there and
it's loud oh that's why there's AC right
there up there you gotta freeze them out
if you put the AC on but it'll get
Frozen and he'll try to get out I just
want to shoot him in the face yeah
um no but the uh the the album is great
man so you do I text you you delivered
you delivered
um always good on the first album of a
three album deal you know what I'm
saying for sure everybody happy I was
gonna ask her now that you're working
with uh with Paul Rosenberg who's
obviously uh for people who don't know
he's a legendary uh executive who also
has been managing Eminem his whole
career and was former head of Def Jam
and has Goliath uh what what how did
this whole I mean the one thing I love
about Paul and M is when they sign
artists they just sign artists that they
like [__] with facts it ain't about the
cloud it ain't about the metrics it's
like yo I [__] with what you're doing
let's see if we can add to that yeah
like they did that with Griselda like
can't say for you what was the initial
like linkage between y'all and like tell
me about that relationship so he started
following me
I would say maybe a year and a half ago
two years ago as soon as he started
following me I DM them Yo management
just before I had my team set up yeah
um he was like y'all [__] what you're
doing any way I can help I got you but
uh I'm not managing nobody no more I'm
done with that I don't have the time or
I don't want I think he used to manage
action right he managed map I think
Blink 182 I was mad people so
um
so basically fast forward I'm doing the
album with scram and scram when the
album we thought it was done he was like
yo let's play it for Paul I'm like
you have to connect he's like yeah
and Paul sat down listen to the album
and he [__] with it and was just like
yo
um give me
a couple months I got y'all I was like
Ah that's that's good enough for me yeah
yeah I waited we waited that was in like
September waited to November he was like
give me to January well this is January
he was like yo I got you it's just
taking long right right right right so
it took maybe almost a year but it was
worth a man of his word absolutely three
album deal yep
Goliath slash virgin and then you had
had some sort of like uh chance with M
back in the day too right like after we
talked about it a bit
they was trying to develop me as the
artist for shady I never met him but I
was [__] with D12 rest in peace proof
yeah
um
but uh Riggs Morales was the a r up
there and he would bring me up there all
the time they you know they wanted to
develop me as one of the artists did
Paul like remember that or was he even
aware of that so they pull I found out
you now that he kind of like blackballed
me from the from the office because I
wrote [__] your life on their door nem's
[__] life in my mind I'm like this is
fire because everybody that walks into
this building now is gonna see nem's
[__] your life and gonna think of me
like when you did it in Compton exactly
exactly yo and I did it in Death Jam
years before right right right right
deal with them at 17 but theirs was
worse I was in their bathroom bro I
wrote it in the mirror on the bathroom
and Mark I don't I look back now I'm
like
[__] what was this wrong with me bro but
um yeah so so he was like y'all told
everybody in the office don't [__] with
you once you did that I was like don't I
don't want this kid coming nowhere near
this building so you know years later
now you're with him absolutely let's go
how has it been he's I mean it's been
amazing Paul is uh
mad he's like us yeah and you know you
know you just hear his name throughout
the years and you know you build it
becomes like a myth but for sure oh he's
just like us I was just talking about
[__] I had Thurston Howell the third on
the show
I think I sent that to Paul
and I was like yo Paul you got bars yeah
and he was like yeah he was like yeah
thirsting how shout out to the low lives
he was like yeah man Rosenberg used to
be rapping in [__] in Brooklyn yeah
in Brownsville yeah yeah Paul said yo me
and M would take the train to
Brownsville crazy in the early days and
go and run I've been going to
Brownsville in the 90s facts yo you
don't want you don't want to go to
Brownsville right now yeah right now so
in the 90s it's like bro but that's also
a testament to who Thurston Howell is
you know he's well respected super solid
dude um but yeah I sent that clip to
Paul and I was like yo how come I didn't
know it he's like yeah Paul Bunyan was
my rap name sick name and also like
visually makes sense bro he's mad Soul
he's like Paul Bunyan facts for sure
shout out to Paul Bunyan man
um for you like I know how big of a deal
it is to have Ghostface on the record
and have a relationship with Ghostface
and have him sit down in the cold on
your podcast like
I know that's a huge deal for you
um bro did I tell you the Ghostface
verse was some [__] vintage Ghost
Face [__] yes you did the verse is crazy
sounds like [__] Enter the 36
Chambers oh my God it's so good man like
I just think it's like I I just think
it's dope to kind of just see like
your your grind like just paying off bro
nah absolutely and ghost he was just at
um we had a release party last Thursday
the night before it dropped he was there
he pulled up pulled up yo super solid
bro super solid like he
like he's really tuned in too he's
tapped in with you know you see these
artists you grow up listening to these
people and you're just like
yo this [__] flying is crazy bro this
fight is mad aggressive yo busy if you
see the fly over there kill that
[__] bro
bro I need you to just take something
and hit it yo give him a weapon give him
a hardeen hat
give him the hard Jean hat we need a
weapon I'm gonna kill this [__]
fly this cockamani bastard it's right up
there it's on the other side of the
pillar oh you don't got no spray bro
what am I gonna [__] rate us out in
here we're in a small room you wanted me
to raid it right there yeah there you go
yeah just hit him with the [__] King
Palm tray bro
[__] ass fly got me [__] up 100 you
killing with that
they used to give it to you now but you
were saying uh so Ghostface came to the
release party release pause yo he's just
super solid bro he's he's I gotta he's
like he's like around five or six all
the time for me in my personal list we
went through this yes Supreme Clientele
one of the best hip-hop albums ever made
yeah I think if you like roll in like
Iron Man
obviously only Built for Cuban links in
his presence on that album he said on my
podcast he don't like Iron Man
he don't like the the his album Iron Man
could it could it be that do you think I
was gonna say I I somehow think liquid
sword somehow does it is like the most
somehow become the most underrated
Wu-Tang album ever because I feel like
it always gets like [__] yes like
trumped when people talk about like only
Built for Cuban links in 36 Chambers I'm
like I don't know Liquid Swords Liquid
Swords is amazing I just recently went
back and listened to it front to back so
[__] good man amazing album and it
does you're absolutely right I think
that's also because jizz is just very
he's very reserved yeah he's an
introvert he didn't have as big a
personality as absolutely as the other
guys absolutely that might be it too
yeah I think that's a lot of it too
shout out to the Rizzo man you ever tap
in with a risen no I met him recently
um but I never tapped him with him like
musically which it would be a dream come
true for sure absolutely I also feel
like he doesn't do a lot so be like if
you get a recipe exactly exactly what
are we doing here facts that's like like
mugs like mugs
he posted I don't have to be a year ago
now but he posted one day like yo I just
found mad old dad tapes from the 90s of
my Beats whoa I hit him immediately like
yo
send me some joints he sent me recently
he sent me like he's supposed to talk
he's supposed to come on my show soon
he's got an album coming out yeah yeah
he's he's text the guy back on my bucket
of this [__] please bring him by and I
and we're I think we're like neighbors
because he walks his dog on my street
all the time and I've never stopped and
been like
yo mugs why because I just think it'd be
super weird but the mugs has an ill
Mystique about him bro in his studio is
like in our neighborhood so it's too
stable here it's in Burbank because it
looks like it because I when we would
just come here I was like this dude
Mike's Studio I could walk there in like
six minutes from my front door okay it's
just this black building next to this
popular Mexican restaurant and it just
the soul assassins A's on it and I
remember I hit my boy I'm like yo it's
mug studio in Burbank yeah it's right
there on Victory I was like yeah that's
crazy yeah right legendary [__] and when
you go bro it's like a time machine in
there he got oh like well once I
interview him I'm gonna try to I Wanna
my goal is to become friends so we can
like walk our dogs together
and then I can be like hey man can I
come and check the studio man yo that
that's that studio I recorded that last
time I was out here I was like bro this
[__] is like so you guys five Beats from
them from the dats from the that's the
old joints some of them are not even
complete but
I'll finish it up that's fire I got you
let's have you uh tapped him with Al yet
Alchemist ow yo unheard story right here
unheard story nobody knows this story
probably five six years ago
I [__] go to Al's crib
pick out a Beat
write it right there on the spot as I'm
writing the first verse
West Side gun comes in big body best is
already there
uh that's gotta be a cool hangout you
and big body best in the same place oh
my God yo [__]
[__] Conway comes in so I'm in I'm in
there's a center like an island in the
kitchen I'm writing it but these
[__] is having wild
conversations I got some other [__] on
my mind that just happened that same day
where I was like I really don't not in
the mood to write but I wrote These two
verses I put it on the beat
we did it after the next day both of us
hit each other was like um I think we
could do something better and I was like
yeah I think we could do something
better too yeah so let's just scrap it
and that's the only time I ever worked
The Alchemist and I'm so tight that that
happened because Alchemist is like one
of my favorite one of the girls
producers and I'm just it just was like
a [__] tornado of [__] that was going
on in my life and literally right there
while I was writing that just took me
off my game where I was just like we
could do better situation up yeah
if you and big body best are in the same
place is it like just like an aggravated
assault felony charge like in the air
absolutely just floating around
absolutely that same time I think the
next day me and him drove to Vegas
together and just oh my God out to Vegas
Vegas with you two would be out because
you're sober now yo but like you're also
you yeah yeah facts I would just be like
yo can we go [__] with prostitutes like
you know my favorite thing to do in
Vegas is like because I used to live
there
like you know I'd like just I'd like to
embarrass old men with their horse
so like uh like I like walk up to like a
dude who's like with like you know
obvious prostitute you know like I'd
like GFE get the GFE going huh
girlfriend experience CFE for the hundo
100 roses
Backpage those were the days 100 roses
ah man
um what for you this album is all you
also you I feel like you're a pretty
vulnerable guy in terms of like a lot of
people know a lot about like a lot of
low points in your life a lot of you
know your battles of addiction and
obviously being incarcerated but on this
album you kind of shared a little bit
about your family life yeah your Pops
passed away from AIDS yeah HIV he hit
contract he contracted HIV from Needles
needles yeah yeah yeah luckily me and my
moms didn't get it
um and yeah passed away when I was four
years old damn and that was probably I
mean I know you talk about kind of like
having a hard time forgiving him
yeah nah that was that was I said that
was gone okay okay
Pops I don't really have that man I have
like two three memories about my father
and one of them is like etched in my
mind it's like like a movie scene now in
my mind when I think about it I remember
walking through the the funeral the the
funeral home my mother bringing me by
the hand and kissing them on his
forehead in this casket that's like one
of the only memories I have in the [__]
yeah yeah facts that's crazy so yeah
yeah that happens and you're kind of
like forced to like grow up and be like
that'll be gotta be the man of the house
from early you know what I'm saying so
it is what it is these things make me
who I am you know all right we got to
stop the interview real quick tell you
about our folks at my bookie our
partners at my Boogeyman listen football
season is approaching it is preseason
right now I can feel it just had my
first Fantasy Draft it's time to get
this [__] money NFL is here go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up for a new
account use the the promo code bootleg
right now when you sign up they're going
to give you that first deposit bonus now
my book is crazy because no matter where
you're at you can go on and get in on
some of that NFL action you can get on
some of that baseball action you can get
in on their Live casino
Blackjack roulette slots whatever you're
into it's going down mybookie.ag all
right sign up right now with that promo
code bootleg they're gonna hook you up
real nice first deposit bonus free money
to gamble with bro when you sign up what
are we talking about football season is
here this is literally my favorite time
of the year as a degenerate we must
participate we got to get a little
action in every Sunday on something
maybe a little Thursday night football
action maybe a little pre-season action
who do you think is going to win the
Super Bowl throw 100 on it [__] it sign
up mybookie.ag use that promo code
bootleg and they're going to get you
hooked up with that first deposit bonus
also want to give a big shout out to our
family at King Palm man want to give a
shout out to King Palm they have the um
sugar Sean
first of all congratulations to Phoenix
Arizona's own sugar Sean for just
winning that title with UFC they did a
collab with them
uh these are the sugar punch honey
orange pre-rolls which are gas all right
now this was dope about King Palm 100
organic all right we're talking about no
tobacco organic leaves and what's dope
is they have these terpene infused tips
that people just love bro they're called
the flavor tips right you're like uh you
bust one of these boys out you know I'm
saying you fill it with your stuff
whatever you want to smoke some of that
flour that you got from Jardine
and then you hit the tip
and man oh I just tasted it right now
just flavor full of Flavor now go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg and you're gonna get half off
whatever's on kpop.com if you don't know
King Palm is everywhere go to your local
smoke shop go to your local 7-Eleven
they got King Palms everywhere so many
flavors
so many Vibes the grapes are gas
yo kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg 50 off let's get back to the
interview yeah 100 man and like you know
adversity and like you said man like and
I'm not the only one that goes through
it so when you put [__] like that on
song there's nine billion people on this
Earth at least 900 million have gone
through the same exact thing or
something even similar not some people
that's what I'm saying that's like the
kind of [__] where like you put that on
like a record and you're like oh man
this is gonna cut through to people
because you do like your [__] like where
you're talking about people having
um feminine benses you know what I'm
saying the C classes but then you also
if you have a record like that it's like
yo man I also like want y'all to like
really sit here with me and like you
know that's some [__] to live to bro I
mean why did why did why do we love
artists like you ain't get it no
why do we love artists like DMX why do
we love artists like Eminem because they
show the vulnerable side there's a
strength and vulnerability 100 you know
what I'm saying and and that those type
of songs and that type of music connects
with people on such a different level
and it becomes and it's Timeless right
right like I could rap about the
feminine bands and then smacking your
moms and punting your daughter but it's
cold for a minute it might get it will
wear out but when you talk about real
[__] it's Timeless 100 I was gonna say
um you you're in a weird space because
there's a gift and a curse to being who
you are because you're
like my kids and like even Bravo the bag
Chaser who was here before you he's like
yo that dude's hilarious and I was like
yeah his album just dropped you know and
he was like he raps yeah and I was like
like at a high level
so like that's a great thing to me
because you have like I mean you've
hosted the crew League I mean there's so
many bags you're getting just based on
you being you that's the best part music
aside yeah like I'm nems you're here
because I'm hilarious but for you as
like an MC is it ever like um
frustrating where you gotta like educate
people that you're a rapper because
you're like oh gee dog like I look at it
I love it it's like it's like becoming a
new artist all over again
um and I know that if they see me there
with the comedy [__] the funny [__]
they're gonna be turned on at some point
to seeing me rap and it's not like my
raps are [__] like I'm not I'm
saying it as humbly as possible like I
could rap you know what I'm saying so
you're gonna see something of me like oh
[__] I didn't even know and then so for
you it's like one hand washes the other
absolutely because you have like two
audiences and if like hey no rapper is
touching my demographic like I'm known
by people three years old to 70 years
old
all Races wherever I go no rapper got
that demographic no for sure
has there uh
what I love is when you my favorite [__]
on the internet the last like decade is
you've making fun of people uh while
they walk by don't ever disrespect me
it's the best [__] ever uh
who did I just see acknowledge your [__]
but they didn't know your name there was
oh Roseanne Roseanne it was Roseanne she
was on Theo Bond yes yes she was like
talking about you no mad people sent me
that yeah she was talking about you but
she didn't know who you were she was
like you ever you see this guy that
don't don't you that she was like doing
your whole bit I love that how crazy is
that to have Roseanne Barr [__]
acknowledge you crazy shout out to
Roseanne she's a ghost
I'll let her give me a [__]
they say it yeah like I always say that
like you know it's about all about the
story facts yeah and I mean Frozen
Roseanne was jerking off [__] Tom
Arnold in the 90s bro I definitely got a
shot no I think I think Roseanne would
manually stimulate you like thanks for
let me beat I think so
did you DM her nah maybe I should I
think I mean she knows who you are now
all you got to do is hit her with the DM
and say hey Roseanne thank you for the
love nah don't ever jump me
not knowing my name you owe me a hand
job now yeah you know what I'm saying I
mean if you got a Roseanne hand job that
would be uh I mean honestly like I might
I might post it on the gram
yeah just that's clout yeah spit no spit
Lube raw dog raw dog you ever have a
chick uh I always say uh
you ever go to a restaurant and they
give you the salt and pepper I always
say uh that's sexually that's the tell
me when to stop
when the waitress is over your plate
tell me when to stop
yeah you know what I'm saying when you
got that goddamn that pepper grinder
gear you know I mean you know you know
what I saw last night who knew who I was
and was like very like
engaged in like wanting me to come on
her show
Alexis Texas do you remember Alexis
Texas she wanted me to come on her [__]
too
[Music]
he looks way better in person yes than
she does on the gram or in the movies so
she shook my hand and she was like Hey
and she's cool super nice so she was
like hey Alexis Texas
and I was like
oh you are Alexis Texas
I was with her probably
a month ago wow I saw her saw her right
at the comment came out scram Jones
Studio My Man album was with a was like
yo she wants you to be on the podcast
I'm like all right
she has a pop-up podcast but let her
know we don't hold no punches we're
gonna be talking crazy yeah she was like
bring it on what has been the drawbacks
of doing a podcast on the sidewalk
outside in Coney Island uh
you know what
my own people like my crew they [__]
talk up a storm like they don't know
they're in the background just shooting
the [__] arguing and they know what
we're doing they like my fake security
like yo make sure nobody walks by and
then people walk by I'm like bro yo yo
we should trade randomly yelling when
the car somebody ain't knowing the car
yeah we over here doing the podcast you
heard I'm like bro come on man you know
it's your own people all the time
um also doing it in the winter probably
sucks in the winter
luckily New York this winter wasn't bad
at all I don't even think it snowed once
shout out global warming you know what
I'm saying but I don't think it snowed
not once we did the whole first season
during the winter we had ghost face in
the winter we had cannabis
hey that was the greatest question ever
nobody ever said that to him what'd you
say to cannabis I said yo
I introduced him I said yo send to the
right of me
you might got more cash than him but you
ain't got the skills to eat at the glass
like him he was like yo I didn't know
what I was saying
wait yo probably one of the wildest
lines ever yes
ever you ain't got the skills to eat at
ass like to eat a Man's Ass Like Me
crazy
I interviewed cannabis nice guy he's a
nice guy very peculiar
you know I had to FaceTime him before he
came on to the show
so I'm just like he had to meet me to
make sure I wasn't trying to I don't I
don't know so I'm FaceTiming them and
I'm like
is this [__] on a houseboat
right he's yo he I I don't know if he
lives there he was on the house he was
on the house he was on a boat he had a
whole living room but then had that you
could see like the outside it was weird
well he was telling me he does like HVAC
work
I don't know
he was a he got mad because like right
right around the time he came on my show
like LL had just like said something
about like
like how they buried the hatchet or just
giving them props that I think like his
Hall of Fame speech or something he like
gave cannabis props yeah he [__]
revitalized his whole career and um even
though LL is a goat of course but
I brought that [__] up and like cannabis
was mad bro really he just didn't like
me bringing up that [__] because like
it's the bit it's the dead horse but
it's also like bro this is like
I mean this is like an unavoidable yeah
part of your career bro it's like it's
like if it it's almost like look I could
have a conversation with drama without
bringing up 50 Cent pretty confidently
and I could do the same thing with
cannabis but I've never ever in a
million years thought I would sit down
with cannabis because he's such a like
out there guy so I was like yo I want to
have the talk and I've always wanted to
ask yeah yeah with this guy absolutely
yeah one one thing I learned about him
from having the conversation with him on
the podcast and you can see it because
is he didn't know or realize
how ill he was true he was saying like
yo I just was rhyming like that to get
on y'all guys level he was talking to me
like I was on that level like I'm like
bro I'm just nice now bro I wasn't nice
you you the reason I'm nice like I am
now but he was like yo I just want to
try to respect my pen and I'm like bro
you didn't know you was that guy back
then like are you crazy like it's you
know you never know what people what
their mind is telling them I also think
like is the The Narrative about his
debut album is just not it wasn't good I
like the album yeah it wasn't good get
[__] was great get [__] was good
Buckingham Palace and trigonometry yeah
the beats the Beats killed them yeah my
clef Beats
none against Wyclef you got fire beast
but that that the pairing of them two
together
and I asked him I was like yo you wrote
freeze verse on that right because I
always wanted to but she said
um I just forgot to remember
extraterrestrial estimates
can't tell you testicles to Mexico that
was like mind-blowing to me when I heard
from [__] 106 in park and I was like
you wrote that right I didn't know all
the time he was like absolutely and I
was like of course you could tell the
flow but you know
these are all questions this is that's
one of the dopest Parts about
gaining this status now in my career is
that I'm appreciative and I have mad
questions that when I meet these people
I can actually ask them should I always
thought about my whole life like always
like had little questions yo did this
ghost face off camera I was asking the
crazy exhibit came to my block was
asking them with stuff mugs came to my
block at Coney Island bro and he sat
with me the whole day I was asking him
crazy [__] about and it's just super
dope how um how often um
you haven't launched season two have you
yeah we just launched it uh we had the
kid Mero and then we had Sebastian
Telfair basketball player sure I I'm
cool I think it's his brother Ethan they
got a dispensary in uh in Arizona yeah
yeah I was gonna say uh how often do you
dropping
every week every week uh but because I
came to LA today we didn't drop this
week so we're dropping next week who's
on me I'm My Own guest I like that my
album came out you know what I'm saying
yo there's this dude named uh dope is
Yola and he does these
oh he does a podcast that's really
popping but he does story time but he
doesn't have guests and he'll just tell
stories he had a wild upbring and he was
like selling drugs and he's Mexican but
his mom's boyfriend was a white
supremacist who got out of prison
so like he grew up in a house like a
white supremacist but he has like these
story time that's what I've been doing
as well I'll be telling like so when I
remember I tell stories about my life
beforehand I got when I remember it this
[__] is funny there'd be everybody else
thinks it's funny to me it's normal yeah
for you uh what is
next on all fronts obviously you're
working on the new album already uh but
I mean you gotta I mean are you affected
by the strike or does that not hit you
yeah did they jump you into sag after
yet nah man I'm trying to get in that
[__]
[__] I got benefits yeah I mean I
think if you make like 27 Grand a year
you get health insurance I'm in there so
they got a boy you gotta be in movies
bro I'm I'm I'm in the musicals on
Broadway
well that's I'm working on that right
now Master Ace got a musical called the
Fallen disposable Arts so he got a
musical based on all those other albums
he put everything
long hot summer yeah yeah yeah
so he got an album called Falling season
but the the his musical is called the
Fallen season and I'm one of the main
characters in The Stream Beyond Broadway
hopefully they're looking for investors
right now yeah yeah facts they haven't
approached you to do like any sort of
like uh acting like a couple people
every time I'm out in La they I have
meetings it's like
I'm at a place where people want Noah
want want to put me on TV and the
opportunities are there we're just not
coming up with the right ideas to get on
there it's like we're stuck with like
after these meetings like yo do you want
us to come up with the ideas or you guys
going to come up with the ideas and it
just becomes a stalemate we was working
on something with Vice and they [__]
went bankrupt yeah they didn't [__]
me working on something with complex and
then they [__] change their whole
staff overnight
um so
um the clothing Line's doing well I know
you guys did you guys you guys ended up
in Zoomies right we got file Brandon
Zumiez Nationwide go to your [__]
local mall wherever you're watching this
this fyl there four different styles and
then schools coming up they're gonna be
putting a lot more
um I got the fyl store and Coney Island
what's like the hardest thing about that
that side once you get into the point
where you are in Zoomies that's I mean
most [__] clothing lines are like we
made it [__] you know what I'm
saying like yeah yeah but I'm sure like
do they test because I've heard like
have to test it this this first run was
the testing phase to see how it sells to
see how it sells and then they come back
and they buy it so it sold well and now
they're buying for back to school so
like the guys I had to go on my
Instagram and delete everything gun
related oh so if I I'm I don't flash
guns on my Instagram or nothing like
that but if I'm wearing a t-shirt with a
gun on it I had to take the post down if
I have my banana clip toys that we've
dropped I remember those we had to take
down everything of that
um Zumiez requested that yes yeah
because Zoomies is heavily anti-gun
which so am I shout out to zombies yeah
we have a great relationship and uh you
know this is a little [__] like that but
I'm a hustler I heard when uh make that
[__] work I was talking to the owner
ethica and he was saying like the first
Zoomies that ever were in was in like
Denver
and he said he flew there
and he took like 10 people with him and
they just went in there and they went to
like the three stores in Denver that
they tested them in and he said well I
just bought it consistently for a week
straight till it was sold out
that's my mom I went on a
um
on a New York wherever I go like I'll
probably while I'm out here I'll
probably stop by the Zoomies that got my
[__]
just show love buy some [__] by the
people that work there some effort yeah
you know throw this [__] on man yeah it
facts yeah because it's kind of like you
want them to push a [__] it's a win-win
it's a win-win for sure gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good Folks at Bluetooth baby that's
right shout out to Bluetooth man listen
everyone's always asking me does blue
true work of course it works because it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
it is Dick season out here bruh you know
what I'm saying you got to make sure
that dick is up to par you know you get
on that blue shoe and uh you're gonna
never like I mean I'm gonna be honest
like
you remember when Barry Bonds hit 70
home runs in a season and now they're
not letting them in the Hall of Fame
like you get off that Bluetooth they're
not gonna let you in the dick Hall of
Fame because it's cheating to be honest
you know what I'm saying so
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
when you sign up now this is what's dope
about Bluetooth because you want to know
if it works well they're gonna send you
a month for free
free Bluetooth in discrete packaging
delivered right to your door but you
have to use the promo code bootleg
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
everything's online no doctor's office
visits no worrying about [__] having
a weird conversation with some [__]
about your [__] [__] no you
[__] bluetooth.com free month online
you don't even have to leave your
[__] apartment you don't have to
leave anywhere you just order it it
comes in the mail and then you know you
you just you know you get to work you
get to work all right so use that promo
code bootleg and get a free month of
blue chew also want to give a big shout
out to our good Folks at Odd Socks now
this is what's up about Odd Socks I'm
about to reach into my Odd Socks bag oh
man
look Odd Socks they got
all of the [__] sick licenses
recently they locked down Coca-Cola
recently they locked down [__]
Transformers Saban Power Rangers we got
Yoo-hoo we got Sour Patch Kids
you know they got their Odd Socks Basics
and I'm telling you the most comfortable
socks in the world in the [__] world
all right and they can all be yours 20
off
20 off using the promo code bootleg if
you go to
oddsoxofficial.com the most comfortable
socks in the world
and they got draws and these draws are
amazing
these are this is this is a small just
so we're clear this is a small yeah
yeah chicks can wear these you know a
lot of chicks like wearing these booty
shorts around the crib and [__]
oddsoxofficial.com whatever you're into
they got the license WWE Scarface
[__] Breaking Bad whatever
autotoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
go over there get 20 off right now let's
get back to the interview
uh
um all right so for you is it now that
you're on Goliath
is it more
because like like this last album we've
been talking about for a while has been
finished for a while right yep are you
going to
try to get another out mount in the next
like six months or what is the plan
probably not probably but then the next
well the next six months will be the
beginning you know on next year yeah
next year probably early next year mid
Earl uh end of winter next year to early
spring
I'm hoping to drop another project does
Paul like ever give you any feedback
like yo M likes this song nah you don't
say nothing about him no I mean not that
he don't say nothing about him but
um
yeah he really don't say nothing about
him yeah I would just I just wonder if
he's like hey yo check out this new guy
on Goliath like who also was almost on
Shady who also tagged our door I'm sure
who also is equally as good not that I'm
sure I don't I don't know I don't know
we don't like I you know I'm sure
everybody asks Paul about M for sure so
I don't want to be that guy as well as
when I turn when I do get the chance to
speak to Paul which is he's always a
phone call away he's great
great great great ahead of um the label
that I'm on I'm totally happy with it
but uh I'm talking about my [__] yeah
I'm busy like yo what's the play yo
what's up I need you to push this button
or because you know or we just
strategizing was there ever uh a bar in
the last like few years now you're more
well known that you just thought was too
crazy that you were like you know what
we're gonna take that bar off the end
there's a couple that I should have took
off that well there's like two verses I
took off the album and replaced
um but also listen I went up to Spotify
like two weeks ago and um Paul came with
me like that and that's like unheard of
the head of a label coming to the
meetings with you which was dope but
listening to it in a room with two women
and well I'm talking about watch your
mouth oh I'll smack a [__] lines like
yo what's happening and I'm like I'm
like oh [__] this don't really hey hey
you're probably like yes
and then even Paul at one point was like
it's very tongue-in-cheek and it's very
you know I was like yeah
almost like you gotta like hey guys look
I'm about to play the song Yes or just
don't play that song
yeah it's like ah
[__]
yeah this is a long song in fact yeah
like hey we could just go to the next
one yeah yeah it just happened you guys
don't have to playlist this one like we
get it you know like I get it like you
know what I'm saying like you know it
also it might not even make the album
after all like just so you know like I
think we might take it off facts when
you sit in the meetings with the with
the corporations and these different
people you're like yeah maybe I should
have said a different
different rhyme right there but it's
cool it is what it is that's what makes
me [__] your life what um is the uh
uh classification between give me the uh
what what qualifies as a a feminine band
and a masculine bends C-Class is a
feminine band there's a it's for baby
mothers those are for single women girls
that do eyelashes and [__] like that you
know what I'm saying nail technicians
you know uh nurses assistant so whatever
nurse texts whatever the [__] Dental
technicians and all that that's true
Jazz secretly no that's like X5 or x3
xx3 yeah yeah no more X5 is cool X5 is
decent X3 is definitely X X5 is decent
if you're under
30. I'm saying after 30 bro you should
be getting it remember evidence from
Dilated Peoples talked about his X5 in a
rap verse ones
try to dilated people's facts facts uh
yeah so so C classes anything outside of
a C-Class is is uh is is passable I mean
C-Class or under you have like a truck
for real like a [__] man's truck what
truck is it I got a [__] Denali oh
yeah you got the [__] Denali bro that
[__] is like sitting in my living room I
love that [__] bro um and you got like
yours do you still have you still have a
camera [__] on you no I'm saying I saw
the rap but you still keep like your
[__] products it's not as intricate
as my last truck
um but I still got merch in my back
because it kind of like makes your truck
not truckable anymore no you know it's
perfect because people
some some of my friends actually think
I'm gonna help them move or some [__]
like that so they're like yo you at the
pickup truck right nah bro it's my story
merch in the back of me go [__] yourself
why would you even ask me to help you
move anyway bro I'd rather pay somebody
to [__] move it for you like leave me
alone yeah I got other [__] to do facts
[__] your life yeah if you have a friend
that'll help you move that's a true
friend
I won't help you move but if they really
need it
[Music]
I'll pay ya yeah like I'd rather pay
even [__] in my house sign goes [__]
up in my house I don't know how to fix
that just call call whoever just get it
you're not like a mechanical kind of no
that's not my style bro no my father
died when I was four bro my mother
didn't know how to do that [__] see yeah
you yo I'll be I feel like I've gotten
into like my uh era of life where I
before I could be doing some man [__]
like you know what I'm saying like I can
fix it a little bit but YouTube man
YouTube University YouTube could do
everything could teach you everything
like I started grilling and [__] yo see
I don't even know how to do that I just
started bro started busy I got that
pellet grill I got that griddle I got a
nice Grill too I just never Grill on it
oh so so you get the griddle though you
could do the [__] Hibachi in the
backyard fire it's great what's your
favorite food Pizza Pizza that would
make I mean that's pizza's like sex even
when it's bad is good I was gonna say
that it's hard to [__] up pizza facts
California does a good job
they're getting better though because I
remember like a couple years ago I would
come out here and the show would be
disgusting now this
they got some decent spots out here me
and my wife always talk about it
California's Pizza is terrible it is
because the spots that the locals are
like this [__] is great it might have
great this is some [__] ass Pizza
absolutely and then you'll go to these
[__] dude I'm in the Valley and this
oh so hard to find a spot that sells
pizza and wings together I'm like what
kind of [__] like who raised y'all
who opened these restaurants why can't I
get hot wings why they got good pizza in
Arizona yeah right actually you know
like the number one rated pizza
restaurant in the United States is in
Arizona it's called Pizzeria Bianco they
actually did a Netflix episode about it
really yeah it's [__] gas I'm gonna
have to go try that out bro because I
don't believe you no it's really good
it's not like a New York style it's like
a wood oven
that's delicious that's so good the
margarita look it up Pizzeria Bianco
it's like ranked like it's always in the
top he knows he knows
yeah it is same with the bagels the New
York water I've heard that about the
bagels yeah Bagels [__] Pizza it's
it's the water is the water supposed to
be better in New York it is absolutely
you could drink the tap water really
absolutely oh [__] I didn't know that
yeah you could drink the tap water in
New York I always figured it'd be the
opposite no it's not I don't know I
don't know how they do it when I think
of New York water I think of the episode
of Seinfeld where Kramer swam in the was
it the river yeah that was just a nasty
yeah but like it's like Coney Island
Coney Island is disgusting I won't go I
go in Coney Island water once a year on
New Year's Day like the Polar Bear
Plunge but I go in that [__] with
sneakers with Tim's it's [__] up the
water
it's not it's green yeah you ever go
partying like uh or like hang out in
like uh like what are the like where the
Hamptons are and [__] where they got all
the [__] yeah yeah it's the same
water it's going down it's the same [__]
yeah yeah it's the same like just more
expensive houses yeah that's it yeah
still the same [__] water uh what
has been the most random moment where
you've kind of pinched yourself in the
last five well let's say three years
um are you just like what the [__] yeah
not well it happens a lot people I meet
a lot of celebrities that are
hyped to see me yeah like they hype when
they get like I'm I'm like oh [__] does
this person like don't ever disrespect
me yo some sometimes it's Ella when they
be like oh I've been loving your raps
and like Ghostface when Ghostface was
like yo I've been a fan of you was like
the first battle rap I really [__]
[__] with wow you know what I'm saying
so I was like yo you meet a lot of these
people you think they don't be watching
they be watching
do you get free next tickets now
huh Nicks ain't never give me not one
ticket bro really not one ticket [__]
the New York Knicks no you gave them a
whole remix oh I gave them a remix I
think for the season [__] rallying
cry bro what he did not do the right
thing at all wait it didn't even offer
oh matter of fact they didn't reach out
I went I did this they reached out for
me to do their celebrity game I did it
and it was like yo whatever whatever
game you want just let us know I just
said I like towards the end of last
season I was like all right let me
redeem these tickets like give me I
don't care what's the game snakes don't
don't disrespect me and give me some
bullshits I need Courtside or I'm not
going yeah every time my Nick hits a
[__] three bing bong bing bro they
never got back well they tried to hit me
with the [__] seat so it had me try
to do some content for them yo give me
these [__] seats I ain't doing [__]
like [__] out of here man hmm
they've been disrespecting me for Mad
Seasons I'm a life I was a lifelong Nick
fan but not no more when I see how they
do business that [__] is disgusting at
least you guys have Brunson that's nice
I don't give a [__] who we got yeah [__]
them
[__] them
go Nets facts I mean Brooklyn no [__]
sixes go [__] sons who gives a [__] I
like that all I care about is the Giants
New York football Giants bro smack the
[__] out the Cardinals do you like
Daniel Jones no I'm doing he had a good
year bro he beat the Vikings in the
playoffs yeah yeah he's growing on me
pause yeah and I think Barkley's out of
there though I think he was not he's bad
he probably does but he's he's here he's
back he's one year [__] contract yeah
yeah [__] idiots yeah if Daniel Jones
is 70 million or whatever seven year
contract to give saquan no [__] I
just don't feel like you should ever
give anyone who played football for Duke
yeah that much money like you played
football at Duke
you know it got to be some racial [__]
bro these they be always they always get
white quarterbacks I mean also they're
[__] over these running backs like
Dalvin cook they [__] he's on the
Jets what the [__] no the Jets on the
low got a squad they got [__] they're
gonna be nice what's his name Sauce
Gardener no Aaron Rodgers and Rogers bro
but the Jets always do that they always
pick up a dope ass quarterback after his
prom yeah that's just picking up a check
is it like a a tense rivalry between the
Giants and jets yeah I mean the Jets
because they they're terrible yeah I
mean they're like the Mets you know what
I'm saying it takes a lot of heart to be
a fan that's to be to be Jets or Mets
fans because you know they're not
winning no time soon it's like Aaron
Rodgers with [__] who was the um the
quarterback they got the a couple years
ago Rivas Revis they don't do nothing
with these [__] stars at the end of
the day like if you're a Jets Mets fan
you probably would forgive your wife for
[__] another man absolutely you
probably walk through on your wife again
and you know what you do you'd be like
I've dealt with my whole life hey hey
guess what
I'm mad right now maybe next year but
I'm gonna go walk it off all right when
I come back these guys better not be
here and my dinner better be ready at
least
take a shower before bed
go Mets
come
anyway yo so the album is out man
everybody should go support rise of the
Silverback is out right now wherever you
listen to music if you [__] watch
this whole [__] and you don't go listen
to the [__] album
[__] your life bro [__] choke on a
dildo what's your
glass or rubber glass go break it
through front teeth yeah you know some
[__] have put a glass dildo in like a
freezer that's some [__] horseshit
gotta be a hole to do that like I
remember like when I was like 19 I
opened this bitch's freezer I was at her
crib in the middle of the night and I
opened her freezer and there was a
[__] dildo in there and I was like
it's like oh yeah it's it's it feels
good like when you when you freeze the
glass dildo I'm like
that's like the glass the kids in the
Christmas story when he puts his tongue
up won't that happen to the [__]
right that's a good point
it's my new [__]
yeah that'd be [__] up bro you'd have
a real uh it'd be a painful
penetration hey yo all right bro oh we
got that Rise of the Silver back out now
bro
where can people buy the merch fyl dot
NYC there's no.com people get confused
like oh there's no.net.com no it's
www.fyl.nyc and if you're in New York
come by the fyl store and if we'll go
buy [__] Zoomies go to Zoomies go to
uh Coney Island get you a Glizzy and go
to the store facts there it is man I
appreciate you pulling up brother oh my
God always nibs hey what up man uh you
just watched another episode of the blue
black cat podcast brought to you by hard
Dean baby shout out to the family at
hardean don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
Jardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Hardin in Las Vegas
the number one dispensary in the world
all right and we are so proud to be
partners with them so shout out to
hardeen go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine